it's time for the launching horoscope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought show you
every Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the laun gene which noir
watts company maker of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching promise Co mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guests for this evening is
the honorable john sherman cooper
senator-elect from Kentucky Senator
Cooper were very happy to welcome you to
Cana scope this evening I'd like to
begin by asking you because of your
experience in the UN whether you think
there's any chance for a truce in Korea
now well as of the moment and
immediately I do not think so this is
always hope but I don't look forward to
any immediate truce I frankly I've never
felt that the Russians won't a truth I
think their action in the UN in recent
days on the resolution the Indian
resolution is good proof of that well
they're not giving up hope though John
MacArthur says that he thinks he has a
clear and definite solution of the
problem do you think in view of that
that general eisenhower or to consult
with them now well of course that's the
question for generalizing there
I would guess that he would he would
find out what his plan is I think he
would do that I think
well what steps do you think can be
taken to put pressure on the Chinese
Communist to want a truce well I think
you've always got to think of this
Korean question as as part of the of the
larger difficulties between Russia and
the rest of the world and that you start
out by knowing it it's a difficult
problem in a very long problem because
we are the real force say I believe that
we have got to have the strength in
Korea which will give the greatest
influence to our position well what are
some of the steps that increase our
strength senator do you think not
knowing myself what the military
dispositions are there
I'm not certain as to what how much
should be added but where did if we're
to convince Russia and Russia primarily
that that they cannot win that they must
adjust the position in in Korea that I
think we've got to have the strength
further I certainly favor the
proposition of General Eisenhower that
as quickly as we can we build up the
strength of the South Koreans and then I
would urge strongly that every bit of
influence that we can bring to bear upon
the other members of the United Nations
should be brought to get from them added
military strength added economic
strength well senator cooper our viewers
of course tonight are thinking about the
USS helena out in the pacific and all of
this meeting is going on out there now
so first of all why do you think all of
these cabinet members
being rushed out to see General
Eisenhower and carried aboard by
helicopter and so forth well it's a it's
a good operation welcome a little
melodramatic to you one no I don't think
so i think is very practical
yeah in the first place everybody is
interested in Korea he's just been there
he's got whatever information that he
could get there and I think it's with
his experience that that he has got new
information and perhaps much clearer
viewpoint mr. Dulles has been in
Washington conferring with the State
Department and he has their view and now
they meet together and as a chance to
bring together those different
viewpoints but from very practical
viewpoints I think it'd probably be the
best opportunity he'll have until he
takes the oath of office and perhaps for
a long time after that to get as many of
his advisers together and have the
chance to confer without interruption
well they're talking about other things
besides Korea then I would think so huh
yes well sir one more thing one of the
things that makes you interesting drive
your as I'm sure is that you're
Republican has just been elected to the
Senate down in Kentucky and I believe
that you are the only Republican that
was elected to the Senate in a state
that did not vote for eisenhower is that
correct sir that is true but it just
left a few votes of voting for eyes and
our out of about a million votes
mr. Stevenson carried Kentucky by only
700 votes and yet though Stevenson cared
the state you were elected to the Senate
to buy what was your majority about
29,000 votes now
let me ask you this sir why were you
elected to the Senate what did you have
that General Eisenhower didn't have and
down in Kentucky I'd like to make it
plain that I probably wouldn't be here
on this program it was generalized that
I hadn't been a candidate that's great
why do you think his gave me the chance
but why do you think you you ran ahead
of the ticket in Kentucky sick isn't
because you were well no no I have this
it makes the third race I made for the
senator in six years and of course I
they do know me and I would hope that I
was on the Senate two years and I hope
and they approved of my record there you
are then I was on the ground making a
fight all the time
General Eisenhower came into Kentucky
one day we could have got him back he
would have carried Kentucky but for
about eight or nine months I was on the
ground every day making the fight
well now the Republican Party is it
strong in Kentucky and is it a growing
party there other things that questions
I'll always ask us and you are a
Republican from Kentucky actually miss
Kentucky has a rather strong Republican
Party out of about a million registered
votes we have a registered vote of about
425 thousand registered Republicans and
we cast it consistently a good
Republican vote since 1900 we've had
five out of the 15 governors but you're
about the first republican has been sent
to Congress by Kentucky in 25 years
weren't you in 1946 well in 19 and 46 I
was the first one who had been elected
to the Senate to the Senate and 25 years
well coming from a border state as you
do sir and from a state that has a
strong Republican Party what do you
think of the Republican Party's chances
of making the south a real two-party
system in south my state is as you said
a border state and
that category you could class West
Virginia Missouri Oklahoma and I think
even Tennessee I think that all of those
states those four states have
possibilities to become Republican
states are released to be in a position
where they could turn Republican
majorities much more often and I think
that it's a problem of getting more
interest from the outside from the in
Kentucky and these border states and in
the parties in those states watching
their leadership having good programs
and and doing the best to develop their
own party I think the situation in the
south is different I while our state is
not typically a southern state
politically we have some of the same
problems we have the problem of not
having local and state administration's
which give you continuity what I think
can be done in the south is to take
advantage of the Eisenhower victory to
take into the leadership some of the
Democrats who voted and for General
Eisenhower taking that leadership even
more importantly the young people who
came under his banner this year did ask
our although you were a Republican you
have been serving as a delegate on the
UN haven't you under the as an appointee
of the Truman administrators I served as
a delegate in 1949 and because of your
experience there I'd like to ask you
some questions about the UN first do you
think the in the United Nations is a
success well it's it's not a success in
the terms that people have hoped I think
it's had a success so I think it's great
success is that it's it's been an
instrument instrument which has held
together the nations who are members
other than the satellite nations and
Russia and kept them pretty generally up
on together
as against Russian domination and
aggression
well hazards one of his chief effects
been to act as a sounding board for
Russia and propaganda against the United
States
yes it's given Russia a forum it's also
given the United States Great Britain
smaller countries a forum also it is
given the other nations of the world at
least the representatives are there a
chance to see the Russians to hear them
and analyze their propaganda and I think
that's been of definite value well sir
our viewers I'm sure would like to have
your views on what the Republican Party
is likely to do on domestic issues on
January the 20th first of all sir do you
believe that the Republican Party will
reduce taxes I think it will take the
steps which will lead to reduction of
taxes
I think reduction of taxes depends we
all know upon what happens in Korea in
general war you think that the the
Republican Party will attempt to repeal
any of the so-called social legislation
and that's been built up by the new and
fair deals in detail there may be
specific laws will be repealed in
general I think the general programs of
Social Security of the wage and hour law
some labor legislation when I can tell
with no copra my will be maintained but
they will be examined and analyzed when
are you come from a state that has a
considerable labor vote do you think
that there'll be more strikes under
Republican administration than they have
been I have the belief that there will
be fewer strikes and I I think we've
already seen some evidence of that since
the election that some strikes are being
sudden the reason I say that is I
believe that when labor knows and
capital as well but I think protects
late labor because I think it's
generally understood
they've had a I think a stronger
advocate that and the merits always
should provide when they know now that
they've got to do what they say they
want to do bargain collectively well
then you're going to have better chances
for agreement well well I'm sorry sir I
time has happened thank you for being
with us thank you very much the opinions
you've heard our speakers expressed
tonight are entirely their own the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Crona scope was mr. William
Bradford GUI and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guests was the honorable
john sherman cooper senator-elect from
kentucky
under any Christmas tree it's the little
packages which intrigue what can it be
we say and this Christmas many hope that
in one like this there'll be a launching
the world's most honored watch truly
throughout the world no other name on a
Christmas watch means so much as the
name long gene in the whole world there
are a few watches to equal long gene and
quality and none of such great renown
among the finest watches of the world
launching alone has won 10 world's fair
grand prizes twenty eight gold medal
awards and so many honors for accuracy
now if this Christmas you wish to give
the gift of great prestige why not
along Jean every long gene watch is
superlative in styling superb in finish
unsurpassed for faithful timekeeping yet
unbelievably you may buy and proudly
give a long Jean watch this Christmas
for as little as seventy one fifty
launching the world's most honored watch
the world's most honored Christmas gift
premier product of the laun jean wit nor
watch company since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches of the highest
character we invite you to join us every
monday wednesday and friday evening at
the same time for the long gene Khurana
scope a television journal of important
issues of the hour broadcast on behalf
of launching the world's most honored
watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honoured long
gene
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host frank night reminding you
that long jean and wit nor watchers are
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for long jean wit nor watches
Tuesday nights there
the honored is gone gene watches have
won 10 world's fair grand prizes twenty
eight gold medals and more honors for
accuracy than any other timepiece
launching the world's most honored watch
is made and guaranteed by the long gene
with no watch company it's time for the
long gene Khurana scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour for show you every Monday Wednesday
and Friday a presentation of the laun
gene which snore what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the Long
Gene prana scope mr. Donald I Rodgers an
editor of the New York Herald Tribune
and mr. William Bradford Huie editor of
the american mercury our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
a s mike maloney
United States Senator from Oklahoma the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers senator Monroe nee our
great connoisseur audience remembers you
sir as a very energetic young freshman
senator who want to write a dramatic
victory in Oklahoma last year and first
I think they'd like to locate you in the
political firmament
I believe you're a Democrat aren't you
say indeed a hermits you a and and you
call yourself a fair dealer
I wouldn't hardly call myself for a
dealer I call myself a good Democrat
with the Democrats generally but time
and again I call them as I see them and
sometimes I can't go on in general
however you are supporter of the
administration in general yes I think
we're on the right policy to help this
country find prosperity and peace but
I'm sure that our audience would like to
have your reactions on the corruption
issues now are you concerned over the
corruption stories that are breaking
daily in the press
indeed I am I think it's one of the
greatest problems this country faces is
to continue to give efficient honest
government and we cannot tolerate
anything less I think the important
thing about the corruption that has been
uncovered it has been uncovered by a
Democratic Congress in both houses and
that the committees that have been
investigating you have been chairman by
by Democrats you are not sweeping the
dirt under the rug do you think it's a
problem of the country or a problem of
the administration I think it's a
problem of both I think you're always
going to have a certain percentage of
man of bad faith when you have large
sums of money being handled and large
problems to handle the important thing
is to prosecute those to the fullest
extent of your ability and to be sure
that any dereliction of duty is
thoroughly cleaned up you feel that the
president has been prone to sidestep the
issue I don't believe he has I think
he's moved in just as strong as he can
on this corruption I think the changes
that have been made and will be made
well Cru that we're going to clean this
up just as fast as thoroughly as it can
be done do you think perhaps sir that
the situation reflects some laxity in
the White House itself I couldn't say
that there have been mistakes and
appointments perhaps and then I think
the system probably is wrong I think one
of the things bad and that concerns me
the most is the things that are coming
out about the internal revenue
department I believe that the political
appointments is the wrong system to
trust to political henchmen the
collection of 60 billions of dollars I
think it ought to be career work now
senator senator Dirksen of Illinois
stated on this show not long ago
that he thought that there was some he
called it collapse of conscience in the
country or that the country was losing
some of its capacity for moral
indignation now what are your views on
that line sir well sir I can certainly
say mr. Ewing that the country is
properly indignant that Congress is
properly indignant and the fact that the
important thing about this corruption
issue is that it is being cleaned out
and will be cleaned out if the country
was tolerating it the country just
shrugged their shoulders said well it's
always going to be some of this and what
can you do about it that would be
something to worry about the fact is
you're out to get it and you're out to
clean it up do you feel that this will
have some impact on the forthcoming
elections undoubtedly it will be a part
of the campaign and be one of the things
that Democrats will probably be called
to account for works to their detriment
unless the things properly cleaned up
and I believe it will be properly
cleaned up and the guilty people
punished and the system that is wrong
and by that I mean the system used by
both parties and that's political
appointments for internal revenue
positions shall be changed to civil
service and career appointments now
speaking of the next election sir I
believe that you have just been had
something to do with the investigation
of the Ohio elections and the amount of
money spent in the re-election of
Senator Ted yeah that's right mr. Ewing
now what conclusions have you reached
after investigating that election well
this is not the first state we've been
in we've investigated several states
Maryland Ohio Iowa and several others
we've come to conclusion that we've got
to tighten up the loopholes in the
Corrupt Practices Act was passed in 1925
and the limits that fix $10,000 for a
state of New York or for the state of
California these tremendous are Omaha is
entirely unrealistic in the light of
today's demands and you're always going
to have money spent in excess of those
amounts unless you correct the loopholes
and put a realistic limit in and make
the candidate accountable for every dime
that is spent in his behalf
whether by satellite organization or
whether by the candidum saying you
didn't investigate Ohio and
deliberate effort to discredit senator
tab I think I think senator tester Huey
will say it was a very fair
investigation in fact we've gotten were
complaints from the Ferguson side
because we investigated both Tony yeah
how do you go about or how would you go
about amending the corrupt practices act
to eliminate so much money being spent
during an election well I think in the
first place you ought to put a realistic
limit on what can be spent to say ten
thousand dollars to win the Senate seat
in Ohio is entirely fantastic you didn't
have television radio you can have
colored printing or billboards or any of
the things in 1925 that are mandatory to
be used in a campaign today
raise the ante wide raise the ante
probably to two hundred and fifty
thousand or half a million dollars if
necessary in these big states and then
require an absolute accounting for every
dime that's spent whether by the
candidate or by the satellite
organizations that now spend money in
his behalf ostensibly without the
candidate knowing that is being spent
now let's relate your conclusions to the
probabilities of 1952 sir
do you anticipate a very vigorous
campaign in 52 well I think it'll be one
of the bitterest and perhaps one of the
dirtiest political campaigns in history
unless the Congress passes a new set of
markers of Queensbury rules we're going
to have to have some some pattern with
which both parties can live by and
observe you think there may be we may
set a record in Nice and expenditures
and that something is to I think it
would be easily possible if you consider
I think a million two hundred thousand
being spent in the TAF campaign and by
his supporters for other portions of the
Republican ticket and perhaps 800,000
for the Democratic side you get into
pretty fantastic sums for one of the 48
states but we also set a national record
and mudslinging well I think that's
liable to be one of the dangers and
we're trying to work on this scrilla tea
and defamatory statements i think that
is another danger that you can tear up
the very fabric of government are you
going to limit inside fighting of that
well we're trying to do it on Senate
races by giving notice now in the Senate
rules that a man campaigned the type of
campaign that he runs will be one of the
manners in which he's judged for his
qualifications to be a member of the
United States Senate senator you are
from a border state
so I audience tonight would be very much
interested in your predictions for 1952
now specifically do you think the
president would be a candidate to
succeed himself
machee I don't believe he will that's
only a guess no one has ever told me but
I've observed political scene both as a
political writer and now as a
congressman of how the senator then whom
who do you think will be the Democratic
nominee of course my guess is that
Speaker Sam Rayburn will be the logical
man to be the Democratic why do you
think Sam labor and will be the man well
in the first place he's held a number
two job in this country which you
speaker the house is far more important
the vice presidency longer than any man
who utters any man that has ever served
in the House of Representatives is a
supporter of Sam Ray words and you've
got the hundreds of them throughout the
country in all 48 states who believe any
men respecting what about his political
location as the Democrats haven't
nominated the southerner for president
in many years that's right but Sam
fortunately has demonstrated over the
years that he's been Speaker of the
House a complete fairness for both the
north and the south and you can ask any
man from New York or Connecticut or
Massachusetts or any of the northern
states has ever served in the House with
Raburn and you'll find that they'll say
at all times that Mr Rayburn has been
extremely fair now as to political
settlement in your state if the election
were held today sir and the race were
between mr. Wrayburn and Senator Taft
how do you think Oklahoma would go well
I really believe Oklahoma would go for a
mr. Wrayburn undoubtedly suppose the
race were between mr. Wrayburn and mr.
Eisenhower General Eisenhower mr.
Eisenhower would make a very very hard
candidate to beat the only way you could
beat him perhaps would be to connect him
up with the Republican Congress that
he'd have to work
with during the four years if you were
elected and run the Republican
Congressional Record do you think that
the General Eisenhower will be a
candidate well of course there's been
awful lot of congressmen and Senators
and others trying to find out the answer
to that question my guess is that he
will not be a candidate
I'd like one other observation from you
sir
senators Mather is a young man myself
was Ontario I'm from the other night and
we were talking about what the young
congressman of thinking are you hopeful
this year about what's going to happen
to this country sir because I feel a lot
better about it this as we finish this
year than I did it to start because I
believe we're beginning to see our way
through this cold and partially hot war
you think 1952 will be a year of war
economy and high taxes as Oh Indy as
well it will still have our restrictions
on building and priorities and things of
that kind
I don't believe you can get taxes any
higher I believe they reached about the
point of diminishing renewals will be
though yeah we hope so senator as I
understand what you've said in the night
you are quite concerned about the
corruption issue you are interested in
putting a ceiling on expenditures and
you think that we're going to have a
very hot presidential race in 1952
thank you very much for coming up from
Washington being witasick thank you very
much the editorial board for this
edition of the launching horoscope was
mr. Donald I Rogers and mr. William
Bradford Huie
our distinguished guests was the
honorable Aires Mike Maroney United
States Senator from Oklahoma
now here is a quick and easy lesson on
an important subject how to buy a
Christmas gift wash just look at this
enlarged long gene watch movement it's a
beauty isn't it and yet how can you and
I be sure that it's a truly fine
mechanism now there is a way to judge
any watch and loan gene told you about
it in this magazine advertisement which
you may have seen here is the
advertisement and here isn't is enlarged
now you can judge any watch by its
record of honors and accomplishments
throughout the world and here is the
long gene record at World's Fairs and
international expositions launching
watches have one highest honours in
every single competition they've entered
the total ten world's fair grand prizes
and twenty eight gold medals in accuracy
competitions at the National
observatories the record of lawn gene
watches is equally extraordinary since
1878 prize after prize and right now the
record for wristwatch accuracy at Nortel
Observatory is held by lawn gene and so
it goes in every field of precise timing
a unique record of launching honours and
achievements all over the world now what
does this record prove it proves one
thing very conclusively throughout the
world no other name on a Christmas gift
watch means so much as launching the
world's most honored watch and if you
pay seventy 150 or more for a Christmas
watch you're paying the price of a lone
gene so why not insist on getting a long
gene the world's most honored watch
premiere product of the lawn gene but
nor watch company since eighteen sixty
six maker of watches of the highest
character
this is Franklin again inviting you to
join us every Monday Wednesday and
Friday at the same time for the long
gene Cronus code a television journal of
the important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches
the honored wha-wha-wha is launching
watches have won 10 world's fair grand
prizes twenty eight gold medals and more
honors for accuracy than any other
timepiece launching the world's most
honored watch is made and guaranteed by
the long gene with no watch company
it's time for the launching promised Oh
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour
trot show you every Monday Wednesday and
Friday a presentation of the laun gene
which nor what's company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
this is frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching chrono scope mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt editor of
the freeman and contributing editor for
newsweek magazine our distinguished
guest for this evening is the honorable
Estes Kefauver United States Senator
from Tennessee the opinions expressed
are necessarily those of the speakers
senator Kefauver the members of our
Chronicle audience of course remember
you sir from you're sensational crime
investigations they know that you are
the vigorous Tennessean who now aspires
to the Democratic nomination for the
presidency and tonight our audience will
appreciate the views on some of your
political views now sir what if you are
running for the Democratic nomination
what is your present criticism of what
is your principle criticism of the
Democrat Democratic administration that
now exists mr. Healy I think I maybe
make this very clear in the beginning
that I'm running on my own I'm not I
think that we have had a too great and
fine Democratic administrations I have
supported the foreign policy and the
economic and social program both
President Roosevelt and President Truman
you're a new donor and a dealer well I
don't I don't testify myself as a on the
dealers I believe in progress and you
want to say a new dealer affair dealer I
believe
that the American people have made great
advancement both in our foreign policy
and in our domestic policy under the
last two Democratic administrations you
want to know why I'm running for
president I feel that of course every
American boy aspires to run I want to do
what I can to see that we continue on
with an aggressive foreign policy that
we do not abandon our place of
leadership in the world also I'm very
much interested in seeing we continue to
have our social and economic gains I do
want to place additional emphasis upon
the necessity of taking affirmative
action and they effort against
corruption I want us to see the federal
government taking more leading part both
Congress and the executive department
and leadership in that respect but in in
the main so why do I feel that we must
get on a sounder financial basis that we
cannot go on year after year on basis of
deficit financing and I think mr. Guha
that there's room for a youth I don't
call myself young because I'm not as you
know but I think there is room for new
ideas and younger people in both of our
political parties well senator I take it
then that if there are two issues
between you and the president one of
them is that you don't feel that there
has been sufficiently drastic dealing
with the corruption issue or
sufficiently adequate dealing with it
and that you are a little worried about
the spending program with those but I
think in fairness today that the a great
deal has been done I think both in
government and out in this effort but I
think in Congress and in the executive
department in in our country generally
at all levels of government that we
ought to place more emphasis upon the
effort against the racket clear in the
wrongdoer because of course I have had a
more intimate familiarity with the
condition in the
today's and perhaps some other people so
it doesn't press me as being something
that we must but take a positive action
all along the line and at every level of
government among our people but you
think that is really the issue and I
would see it I'm not trying to drive I'm
not trying to draw issues between mr.
Truman and myself or between anyone else
in myself running because I feel that I
have the qualifications that I've had
the experience and that I have the ideas
for the future of America which the
American people want and which will
appeal to the voters of America well the
Senate but of course there are
differences as you have pointed out on
basic philosophy though you you are and
since our people must make some choices
in 1952 on basic philosophy you approve
most of what was done domestically and
in foreign policy in the Roosevelt
administration's and also in the Truman
administration yes that's right mr.
Dewey as a political figure you want to
extend the philosophy of the Roosevelt
and Truman administration's generally
that's true and I want to see them
carried on vigorously I think I do have
some minor points of difference as to
our foreign policy but I think that we
have done well in maintaining and
carrying out our position of leadership
in the world and interest at peace you
are not out there today I think that we
did a I think in the United Nations and
in the Atlantic pact that we have done
things that were necessary along that
line and you are not concerned with our
our being overextended abroad you
believe that we do have commitments
abroad and that we must continue to
spend large sums of money abroad and we
must continue to stationed American
troops abroad and be generally concerned
greatly concerned with what goes on in
the rest of the world yes I do I think
that we have to share our part of the
responsibility along with
other nations of the North Atlantic I
think that we must join other three
people in the interest of peace I think
that we must build toward a system of
collective security that's going to
reverse the trend of war every 25 years
I ask you the exact commitments as to
how much we should spend on military aid
abroad or economic assistance I have a
feeling frankly that over a long period
of time unless we get into an actual
Lord or unless the condition gets worse
that we are going to have to trim down
even our defence spending so that we
will not be bankrupting ourselves in our
Armed Services Committee we have seen a
great deal of waste both both in
military spending abroad and in the
handling of our armed services
here we are watchdog committee there I'm
on a sofa Lyndon Johnson committee
that's well let me get this clear sir
so basically you feel that the country
would be better off in 1952 electing
another Democratic administration so
that you could continue to carry on
what's been put in motion by Roosevelt
and Truman yes that's because I
certainly do mr. fury I think that we
should have another Democratic
administration of course I hope that I
have a part in it but I think it's very
vital for the country that we do elect a
Democrat any of us because we do have a
philosophy I think the general course
that we have been going is all right is
in the public interest I don't know fish
direction and the way a foreign policy
we go if we had a Republican
administration and I think the fact that
the Republican Party generally has
opposed the economic and social gains
the resource development that we have
had in the country although many of them
have favored it but as a party they have
opposed it where they're not speak well
for the future of those programs under a
Republican administration
well senator most of the people who
discussed your candidacy say that you
face opposition
in the Democratic Party from two ends
now the Southern Democrats are supposed
to think that you're too much in favor
of the fair deal and some of the
administration Democrats feel that you
have been taking too drastic a position
or on the question of corruption now
would you like to comment on that yes I
certainly read mr. Haslett that's quite
true I do face opposition from both in
the south and both in the north all of
its points out that I think it's going
to be very difficult for us to have any
president who will meet the exact
formula of any section of the country
and I think that intersection that
expects that is just not looking at it
from an overall viewpoint I feel that my
position is that one that does take into
consideration the various parts of the
country and that's what I'm going to
present to the people why do I think
they I think they will understand that
they know section of the country can
have a man just exactly like the one
they want why do you think the president
first took his name out of the primaries
of New Hampshire and then decided to put
it back in again of you any theory on
that
well mr. hasni I have enough trouble
keeping up with my own difficulties
without trying to guess or speculate
about somebody else's that all I know is
that read in the paper that mr. McKenna
thought that for organizational reasons
that the president should go back in the
New Hampshire primary I think the idea
being that the political organization
very might suffer if he doesn't allows
name to remain on the counter but I
never exactly understood how that was
true but as a final question senator
Keith Osso why do you think are the
chief issues that will be decided by the
voters in the coming campaign are you
talking about no I'm talking about the
presidential campaign yeah
I think the general thing is issue is
the one of foreign policy are we going
to go on and strengthen and better our
foreign policy and follow through with
our position of leadership or are we
going to turn back and hedge and go to
some extent sent back to isolation I
think that's on one side and I think on
the other side that the American people
are going to believe that the democratic
party can better be be better trusted to
carry out our social and economic
program than the Republican Party I
think on those two things would be an
issue of course a a big issue in
government at this time is cleaning up
any crime and corruption
taking leadership in the interest of
battle against the cartel of crime that
I would very much senator Kefauver being
rid of tonight I'm afraid where our time
is up Thank You mr. husband the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Cana scope was mr. William
Bradford Huie and mr. Henry Hazlitt our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Estes Kefauver United States Senator
from Tennessee
neither the eye nor the camera can
determine a winner at the events in the
Winter Olympics at Oslo the winner is
determined by the world honored watch
lon Jean the watch of first choice for
timing championship sports in all fields
now why there is one reason and one
reason alone the greater accuracy of
launching watches of all types examine
the records of the accuracy trials that
the great government observatories and
you'll find proof of this statement that
is why championship sports in all fields
throughout the world choose launching
the world's most honored watch for
official timing by national and
international sports and contest
associations have named laun Jean as the
facial watch among these are the
American Automobile Association the
American powerboat Association and the
National Aeronautics Association just so
it's the greater accuracy of launching
watches of all types that is made laun
Jean the first choice with
discriminating men and women everywhere
so if you wish to buy the quality watch
of all the world either for yourself or
as a gift you too should choose lon Jean
premier product of the lawn Jean with
nor watch company lawn Jean official
watch Olympic Winter Games of 1952
join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at this same time for the
long gene coma scope a television
journal of the important issues of they
are broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and with noor
distinguished companion to the world
honored long gene sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches this is rank night
speaking
it's time for the launching sauna stove
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and friday a
presentation of the laun gene which
snore what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
david ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the long
gene chronicle mr. William Bradford Huie
editor of the american mercury and mr.
donald i Rodgers an editor of The Herald
Tribune our distinguished guest for this
evening is the honorable Everett Dirksen
United States Senator from Illinois the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers senator Dirksen is one
of the leading Republican spokesmen in
Congress and also of the presidential
campaign we'd like some of your current
views from Washington now I understand
sir that you have just recently
introduced a bill in the Senate which
would limit the powers of the wage
stabilization board and since the WSB is
tied so directly with the steel
situation or we should tell us something
about it well mr. Rogers you're quite
correct as a matter of fact there is
pending in the Senate Banking Committee
at the present time an amendment that I
offer to the defense production act it
springs out of the steel controversy in
essence of course it would give
statutory authority the weight
stabilization board which exists today
as a matter of fact only under executive
authority and executive order and
secondly it would send back issues like
union-shop and representation to the
National Labor Relations Board for
administration under the taft-hartley
Act as designed by Congress in the first
instance you do not feel that these
belong with the WSB that's quite correct
and then there's one other very
important aspect of this amendment and
that is that's a number of members
on the board or public members must
exceed the aggregate of industry and
labor members and the public members
would be confirmed by the Senate why do
you why do you insist on this Senator
Dirksen do you feel at the wage
stabilization board as it is presently
constituted is slanted toward labor well
as a matter of fact I sat through most
of the testimony including that of
Governor Arnold the price administrator
mr. Roger Putnam the economic
stabilization administrator and also mr.
fine singer and then later on of course
we had Charlie Wilson and I came to the
conclusion from the testimony that they
were more interested in labor of peace
and they were in the principal that was
involved and that you got some rather
oblige sentiment and for that reason I
want to see the public members of the
board confirmed by the Senate because
then at least we can be sure we are
going to get public members who
represent the public interest well
Senate there now
at present the wage stabilization board
has 18 members hasn't it that's correct
and six Alama from labor and six of them
supposedly from industry and six of them
supposedly represent the public oh
that's right and none of them are
confirmed by the Senate none whatsoever
and all are appointed by the President
and what you want to do is to make most
of them public members and to require
that the Senate approve them so that you
can examine the record and possible
biases of each one of those members as a
matter of fact mr. hero I would have no
objection to making them all public
members because it is the larger public
interest that is involved here and then
have all of them confirmed by the Senate
as a matter of fact when mr. inal was on
our show a couple of weeks ago he said
that it was in the public interest that
he made his decision for the president
to seize the steel industries well that
could be a matter of opinion of course
and when it comes to my own viewpoint
with respect to seizure I think it was
illegal I think it was unjustifiable I
think it was unwarranted and that there
was no constitutional excuse for it
whatsoever think that if the wage
Stabilization Board had a public
membership mr. inal would have been
to reach this conclusion I doubt very
much as a matter of fact and if we had
real public representation on the board
confirmed by the Senate the chances are
that we wouldn't have this controversy
on the national doorstep today
now this Dirksen amendment sir that to
change or to redefine the powers of the
WSB
what what chance do you think that has
of being adopted well I think it has a
fair chance of course I've been sort of
holding the committee a little from time
to time
and if for any reason it fails in the
committee certainly it will be offered
on the Senate floor and I'm of the
opinion of course because of the
controversy now that it will commend
itself to the serious thinking of the
members of the Senate now the
administration as opposed to it all very
definitely so on what grounds sir well
they think of course the board is
presently constituted is doing a good
job and perhaps they don't want to set
up disturb at the present time is there
any evidence from from your constituency
that the WSB is doing a good job
none whatsoever that I know and as a
matter of fact of course people back
home don't know too much about the
operations within the board
I had however a chance to read the
recommendations of the board many times
I read the dissenting views of the labor
members and the industry members and I
come to the conclusion that there was a
little bias there and so in the hope of
eliminating that and also to make sure
there'll be no recurrence of this
difficulty in other industries like oil
and rubber and aluminum that involve the
national interest in the defense effort
I want to see the board reconstituted
and given statutory authority do you in
fear that that will happen that we will
have similar situations saying oil
there's a strike in the oil industry at
the present time well miss Rogers as a
matter of fact the controversy relating
to oil is before a couple of panels in
the wave stabilization board at the
present time
rubber may be there aluminium might come
on and there might be a good many others
and we simply cannot afford it could
very logically progress to the doorstep
of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
exactly so mm-hmm
senator our audience of course is
gravely concerned in this crisis and I'm
sure that they would appreciate a
prediction from you as to how you think
this constitutional crisis is going to
be resolved well mr. Hilley of course
the Supreme Court is not always
predictable as you know and there have
been so many sharp five-to-four dissents
and decisions by the Supreme Court they
might very conceivably not pass on the
seizure issue at all and simply go on
the theory that the taft-hartley Act
which was created by Congress and which
is after all a trustee of Congress
operated by the National Labor Relations
Board has a certain Authority and
certain remedies that have not yet been
exercised and they may very simply say
until all the remedies have been
exercised there is no occasion for them
to pass on the major value are you
saying sir that you don't anticipate an
early decision by the Supreme Court in
this mode not necessarily they may pass
on this very shortly as a matter of fact
because of the high public interest we'd
like one one other observation from you
sir do you think that did anything has
happened to the judiciary that the
American people should be concerned
about is the judiciary is still an
adequate check in balance on executive
power in this country well III don't
like particularly to pass on that
question except to say that I can find
you a lot of people in the country who
have their fingers crossed on that one
and are beginning to wonder whether a
political note has included itself into
the judicial findings in the country
well speaking of crossing the fingers
and the intrusion of political notes
senator Dirksen this afternoon or late
this afternoon the Federal Reserve Board
in Washington announced that it was
withdrawing controls on installment
buying an announcement which I'm sure
will have some profound effect around
the country now do you notice any
political influence in this decision it
means essentially that the last holdout
on controls over the Purchasing over the
vast spending that went on in this
country following the Korean incident is
now lifted well now mr. Rogers if you
bear with me
just a minute I'll give you what I think
is a rounded answer first of all I share
the view that has been expressed by a
number of people in Washington and in
the Senate that by means of control by
means of credit controls by means of
taxes and by means of reduced public
spending we might have kept this thing
in balance without the necessity for the
kind of physical controls that we have
today now then I'm beginning to think as
this thing softens up and I see a
softening of business in a good many
sections of the country that the
administration seems to be interested in
keeping this fake prosperity as I call
it going until Election Day and if you
need authority for it we look at the
president's message on the State of the
Union to the joint session in which he
said the domestic economic issues and
the international matters cannot be
separated
that's just another happy way of saying
that you can't separate the cushy jobs
from the corpses in other words you feel
sir that the administration is
endeavoring to maintain inflation and to
maintain what you call a fake prosperity
until November 4th well when you see the
administration candidates and the
candidates for the presidency around the
country talking about the prosperity
that the Democrats have brought to the
country obviously that's going to be one
of the key issues with them in the
campaign and if they're going to utilize
it and cash in on it they've got to
maintain it and the maintainence you've
got to do certain rather peculiar and
queer things and maybe this is one of
them I'll say what do you mean by faith
prosperity why do you call it a fake
prosperity well mister Huey when every
prosperity is drenched with young blood
I call it fake prosperity and I've got a
better name for it in there I call it
blood and graveyard prosperity you are I
suppose referring to Korea sir well as a
matter of fact and may I mention this
now that you raised Korea what a
singular thing it is that we're
observing the seventh anniversary of VE
Day and here we are immersed in a
struggle 7,000 miles from home where the
casualty list has piled mountain high
and it almost aggregates a hundred and
nine thousand American casualties at the
present time but here you've got surplus
labor going into the defense plants of
the country here under mutual security
and the Marshall Plan and that sort of
thing we are exporting some of the
surpluses from America that is not a
durable prosperity it's got just a
little touch of holy young blood upon it
and that's why I call it a piece of
fakery senator Dirksen you of course
have been very active in the
presidential campaign and I'm sure that
then you're a great leader in the
protest movement against the
administration I'm sure that our
audience would like to have your
prediction now as to how that fight
against the government this year is
going well mr. Hyuga are you referring
to the campaign on the Republican side
of the yes sir I mean well as the world
so well knows I've thrown my marbles in
with Bob Taft
I'm always heartened by the fact that as
I get around the country they say he's
the best that the Republican Party has
and then of course in condition it a
little by saying but of course as you
know he can't win well as a matter of
fact I managed his campaign in Illinois
and we gave him a little over nine
hundred thousand votes as a
demonstration that Bob Taff can win well
thank you oh I'm very much in Baptists
corner because I think he would make a
great president and he may not make the
greatest president that Europe ever had
but he'll be one of the greatest that
America ever had well thank you very
much for being with us tonight sir the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Chronicle was mr. William
Bradford Huie
and mr. Donald I Rodgers our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Everett Dirksen United States Senator
from Illinois
do you have the problem of selecting a
gift of great prestige for someone
important to you well that problem is
most happily solved with launching the
world's most honored watch because of
the fine quality of the watch itself and
because of what the name long Jean
stands for to the whole world launching
stands is the only watch in history to
win the highest of all awards
thirty-eight times at World's Fairs and
international expositions including ten
grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals long gene the world's most
honored watch stands for the watch of
first choice in sports aviation science
and other fields of precise timing lawn
jeanne stands for the only watch to be
classified first at the four great
government observatories washington
geneva q Teddington and russia tell the
gift of great prestige for graduation an
anniversary for any important occasion
is launching the world's most honored
watch and throughout the world no other
name on a watch means so much yet you
may buy and own or buy and proudly give
a lawn gene watch for as little as
seventy one fifty lawn jean the world's
most honored watch premiere product of
the lawn jean wit nor what's company
since eighteen sixty six maker of
watches of the highest character this is
David Ross speaking for your regular
host Frank Knight inviting you to join
us every monday wednesday and friday
evening at the same time for the long
gene chronicle a television journal of
the important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion
world-honored long team sold and service
from coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for long gene
with nor walkers
it's time for the launching promise of a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour a presentation of the
laun gene which snore watts company
maker of launching the world's most
honored watch and wit nor distinguished
companion to the world honored lawn gene
good evening this is David Ross may I
introduce our co-editors for this
edition of the launching Chronicle mr.
William Bradford Huie editor of the
american mercury and Lieutenant Colonel
Ansel Talbert an editor of the New York
Herald Tribune our distinguished guest
for this evening is the honorable Fred a
Seton United States Senator from
Nebraska the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speakers
senator Seaton I believe that you're a
Nebraska newspaperman who's serving out
the term of the late Senator query
tonight sir we'd like you to tell us
something about the unprecedented floods
that you've had in your area now can you
describe for our audience something
about how serious this flood has been
sir yes I'd be glad to mr. Huey this
present Missouri River flawed is the
greatest in the history of man not only
in the history of the white man but also
so far as the archaeologist can tell in
the entire history of the Indians and
anyone who may have come before them how
many people lost their homes or were
driven from their homes as far as we're
able to tell at the moment about 80,000
people had to be evacuated with damage
to a larger percentage of those homes
than not and what was the property
damage we believe it will exceed 300
million dollars now of course this river
has been rampaging and flooding for many
years can you give us some indication of
how much loss there's been over the
period of the last ten or twelve years
well in in actual damages to
installations of buildings of towns of
public utilities of farm fence and barns
and that sort of thing the damage has
been about 1 and 3/4 billion
of dollars Senator Congress has been
blamed in certain quarters for not
appropriating enough money for an
adequate flood control program do you
think that's a fair criticism well of
course as a member of that Congress
Colonel you can hardly ask me to give
you a complete affirmative I would say
that some of the thought has been
Congress's yes and determination of
first things first
probably Congress has missed a little
bit on what was first what do you think
it's a matter of more money or better
plans I think it's a matter of more
money because we have the plan the the
Picts loan plan which was first adopted
in 1944 is thoroughly adequate so far as
taking care of the Missouri River Basin
and its flood situation is concerned
what we need is the money to carry the
plan out you can't stop the flood with
paper our audience would like to know
something about that pick Sloane plan
now is this the plan drawn up by the
Army engineers for controlling the river
it is a composite plan mr. Hill week the
two authors of it were general pick of
the army engineers and Clara Sloan of
the Department of Agriculture
technically it is today known as the
pick Sloan plan with a young amendment
the young amendment came about through
the efforts of a man by the name of
gladwyn Young who carried out the idea
of upper watershed control of the river
so that you didn't start all of your
efforts on the main stem you held some
of the water back in other words on the
farms and the hillsides leading down to
the tributaries of the main stem of the
ran this this is a plan for the
construction by the federal government
of a of a number of dams is that correct
that's correct
about how many dams does is envisioned
in the plan well all in all if you
carried out the complete plan there
would be about a hundred such
installations in the Missouri basin now
remember the Missouri Basin just isn't a
little thing that a river flows down
because actually you've got about 2/6 of
the landmass the United States in that
basin but there are four major dams
involved in it those four dams when
completed would stop a repetition of the
flood we had in 1952 at least how does
this fit into President Truman's planned
I believe involving six billion dollars
for
national flood control is at part of the
president's plan yes I'm glad you use
the word part it is part of course the
president's plan the encompasses a great
many things besides the construction of
these main stem stem dams and the flood
control in the tributaries and on the
farmlands I'd rather not get in the
position of trying to defend the
president's plan of six billion Circa
don't mind
well our audience we know that we can
spend a great deal of money and we can
get some benefits but now just how much
money do I do the people of the United
States have to spend to complete the
Picts own plan to complete the Picts
loan plan again for the job of
controlling these ravaging floods on the
Missouri River would cost the people of
the United States about a billion three
hundred million dollars or four hundred
million dollars less than the floods
have already cost the Dean of the United
States in other words as these floods in
the last ten years it costs the people
of the United States more than it will
cost to build these dams yes that's
right in actual damages now to those
damages now to those floods out there
cost the people in in New York and other
people who live outside that area are
they expensive to us yes definitely so
in at least two ways one may be rather
intangible and difficult to visualize
but we know that whenever you have flood
damage or damage from anything a tornado
which of course you can't control that
you then suffer about a twenty percent
loss and income tax collections now I
assume that everybody listening to this
program pays income taxes in this day
and age in America so you can charge up
twenty percent of this total loss to the
people here in New York State for
instance their share of its are going up
to pay more taxes because those people
out there won't make the money to pay
them now then specifically so far as all
of us are concerned the 1952 flood on
the Missouri River will cost the average
family in the United States at least
fifteen dollars and fifty cents on her
grocery bill because you see the
Missouri Basin is the breadbasket of
America and we know that those losses we
suffered in farm produce
will cause a 1% increase in the cost of
everybody's food for the ensuing year in
other words every family in New York or
Atlanta or Jacksonville Florida or
Chicago every family in the United
States will have to pay 15 dollars more
for food this year because of this flood
is that correct that is correct and
that's a very conservative figure that
we can defend senator flood seemed to be
getting worse and worse in your opinion
have we really accomplished anything in
flood control up to now oh yes colonel
love we could talk all evening about
that but just as far as the Missouri
Basin is concerned the construction of
the Fort Peck Dam which was closed last
year held enough of those flood waters
that have the dam not been there the
flood would have been 2 feet higher at
Omaha Council Bluffs pier in South
Dakota than awaaz well of course it
would just have caused additional
millions and millions of dollars of
damage because the chances are we've
been impossible to hold that flood
within the levees which this which did
hold the flood now the court effect Dam
it has been completed now that's that's
part of your picks own plan it's one of
the four major dams yes sir you're
telling us that because you had that dam
completed the flood was not as bad as it
would have been without that one that's
absolutely correct and each dam that is
now completed will reduce the danger of
in any future flood yes I think
everybody who has studied the river the
Army engineers the civilian authorities
even the people who argue about the
Picts loan plan all will agree that the
four dams when completed would have held
these floodwaters back to the extent
that instead of adding a flood we would
have had a stage of the river about two
feet less than flood height all the way
down the river to where it joins of
Mississippi does that make it clear for
yes one of the issues that divides our
people is the issue on the Tennessee
Valley Authority I think we Americans
are divided into those of us who think
TVA is something pretty great and those
who do not now is there any enthusiasm
in the Missouri Valley for a TV a plan
very little sir and what there is is
engendered primarily by the executive
department United States government and
by the Bureau of the interior of the
federal government well senator thinking
on a national scale in whose hands will
the flood control problems of the future
fall in the army engineers in a national
authority or of course that's a that's a
national question as far as the Missouri
Basin area is concerned are the ten
states out there in the Middle West and
the West if we have our way the control
of this thing will be in the hands of
representatives of those 10 states drawn
from the so-called 10 state compact and
from the governor's conference of those
10 states now are there Fort Peck dam I
believe there's no it's not a
hydroelectric dam is it no it is not
it's just for flood control that's right
now are any of the other that proposed
dams to be hydroelectric dams yes some
of them are however the production of
hydroelectric power or the production of
electrical energy is not a major part of
the pyx loan plan it is interjected into
the plan only so far as it is necessary
to amortize the cost of some of these
dams so that the irrigation water drawn
from the dams will not be prohibitive
and costs to the farmers in short now
our people can understand that in the
Missouri Valley you're not going to have
under that plan ADA a power development
similar to what we've had in the
Tennessee Valley and then out in the
northwest so you will have neither the
emphasis on power that you had in the
Tennessee Valley or you will you have
the extent of manufacture and and and
that area will remain primarily
agricultural then and and and your plan
is designed primarily to aid irrigation
and crop development irrigation of
course with the ensuing crop development
flood control and navigation on the
Missouri at least up to the point of
Omaha
now when Windsor will the pick Sloane
plan for controlling this river when
will it be completed according to the
present schedule well according to the
present schedule on the basis of the
Appropriations which have been made up
to fiscal year 53 it would be
at least 1960 before these major dams
were completed in the major
installations were in on the river now
if we get our way we will try to hurry
that up and certainly cut down that
terminal date by three years anyhow I
see in other words now x-ray length is
eight years it will take eight years to
complete it and you as a senator from
Nebraska are trying to cut down that
time I'm sure that our audience very
much appreciate your views tonight sir
and thank you for being with us the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching Crona scope was mr. William
Bradford Huie and Lieutenant Colonel
Ansel Talbert our distinguished guests
was the honorable Fred a Seton United
States Senator from Nebraska do you have
the problem of selecting a gift of great
prestige for someone important to you
well that problem is most happily solved
with launching the world's most honored
watch because of the fine quality of the
lawn gene watch and because of what the
name lawn gene stands for to the whole
world lawn gene stands as the only watch
in history to win highest of all awards
thirty-eight times at World's Fairs and
international expositions including ten
grand prizes and twenty eight gold
medals lawn gene stands as the watch of
first choice in sports science and other
fields of precise timing and lawn gene
stands for the watch that has one
highest Observatory accuracy honors the
gift of great prestige for any important
occasion his launching the world's most
honored watch and throughout the world
no other name on a watch means so much
yet you may buy and own or buy and
proudly give a lawn gene watch for as
little as seventy one fifty launching
the world's most honored watch premiere
product of the lawn gene wit nor watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
for the lawn Jean Chronicle a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn Jean
sold and serviced from coast to coast by
more than four thousand leading jewelers
who proudly display this emblem agency
for long Jean wit nor watches
it's time for the launching Chronister
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday
a presentation of the laun gene which
nor what's company maker of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn gene good evening this is
David Ross may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching promise Co mr. William
Bradford Huie editor of the american
mercury and mr. Ogden Reid jr. of the
New York Herald Tribune our
distinguished guest for this evening is
the honorable Henry Cabot Lodge jr.
United States Senator from Massachusetts
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speakers mr. Lodge it's a
great pleasure for us to have you
tonight on the lawn giancana scope sir
audience knows you of course says the
distinguished senator from Massachusetts
and tonight we'd like to ask you
something about general Eisenhower's
tactics when he returns here now so can
you tell us first can you tell our
audience what some of general
Eisenhower's plans are when he arrives
in the United States well he plans to
were rot in Washington and then go to
Abilene Kansas where he makes a speech
on me
on the 4th of June on June the 4th he
speaks in Abilene about how many
speeches Thunder Lodge do you think he
should and well make oh you can't tell
that this far ahead what is that a great
mistake to make your plans for the end
of the campaign three months ahead you
shouldn't do that well I understand that
he's we heard the rumor that he was
going on to Colorado and would probably
spend a great deal of June
the best-kept secrets of the whole
campaign I announced it to 6,000 people
in Denver and it never got printed in
the East or Santee large what excuse me
what subjects do you think General
Eisenhower ought to deal with
hard-hitting subjects in these speeches
that he will make what do you think in
short the people in this country would
like to know that they are not clear on
as yet well I think people are pretty
clear about Eisenhower I think most of
the talk about not being clear comes
from the campaign managers of his
opponents and I think one way not to run
a campaign is to run it so to please
your opponent's campaign managers we had
a big victory message the other day and
a lot of people voted for Eisenhower in
fact he ran very strong in the
Democratic primary and some of the tasks
came paint campaign manager said it was
immoral that we wanted to get Democrats
and independents to vote for eisenhower
well in as much as the Republicans only
have 31 percent of the vote how are you
going to win if you don't accept the
Democrats in the independency you're
going to vote the cats and the dogs in
the cars I don't know now senator
there's been a considerable thought and
discussion about big tactics at General
Eisenhower would use and about his being
warned to say it's say nothing
or is being warned to be forthright now
do you expect him to be forthright in
his answers to questions when he returns
here oh there's no question about he
isn't going to have any tactics we've
never had any tactics in this campaign
we feel he's the most popular man which
really is the best qualified man he's
the man everybody wants and our sole job
is to see that that demand is translated
into delegates let's take he's of course
he's going to be forthright he always
has been he's going to be just as
forthright in dealing with domestic
questions and political questions as he
has been dealing with military and
foreign questions there is no doubt
about that
you don't think that then that that he
is going to attempt to follow a tactic
of saying nothing then I think it's
perfectly ridiculous I think that is
just as ridiculous as the rumor that was
put out by his opponents that he was
going to stay in uniform until after the
convention lacus just isn't true he's
going to be in civilian clothes he's
going to be just as free to talk as he
was as president of Columbia I don't
know why they start all those thing
from there obviously fallacious on the
face of them you know welts and a lodge
on tickets because there isn't a real
issue against him so they're trying to
fabricate please
well Sunday lodge for example on certain
questions it's clear where General
Eisenhower stands on the whole subject
of socialism but do you think going from
the principle to the particular he
should deal with particular things that
are current such as the steel strike or
the taft-hartley law well I don't think
he ought to go into legislation that was
enacted the taft-hartley law was enacted
the McNary Hagen bill the Bankhead Jones
Act I don't think he needs to go back
cuz his opponents would like him to say
how he would have voted if he had been a
senator during the last fifteen years
well he wasn't a senator and he wasn't
exactly wasting his time either and I
can imagine no greater waste of the
public's time then it tried to figure
out how he would have voted if he'd been
a senator all those years I just think
that's that's mistakes let's take this I
think issues that involve the future
those are special things that's
something else again the specific issue
of the tidelands oil
I believe he took a specific position on
that in last week did he not and a
letter that was released in Texas I'm
not sure well as I believe it was a
published report by Eisenhower's forces
in Texas Jack Porter that had received a
letter from Eisenhower which seemed to
indicate or they interpreted it that he
had taken the Texas and California
position for states rights on Thailand's
oil did you understand that that way sir
no I didn't understand it quite that way
I I think there were some other thoughts
in the letter he wrote to Jack Porter I
see quite as you think you would you
think it would be a mistake then to take
it as a that Eisenhower has endorsed the
Texas position on tideland
I didn't say that I said his letter to
Jack Porter was not as simple in his
brief because you would indicate I say
there were some other thoughts in there
about oil do you feel Sunday lodging
when General Eisenhower comes back he
will make very clear his
opposition to the administration's
foreign policy in certain areas I can
think offhand particularly the
administration's policy or a lack of
policy which would be more accurate with
regard to China I don't know what he's
going to say he got to make up his own
mind himself he doesn't have to have me
to do that I know that he's always been
critical of the administration's foreign
policy that as far back is plus to him
he told the president that we should
make no concessions to the Russians to
get the mid of the war against Japan and
that if his advice had been followed we
wouldn't have had the mistakes that he
altered and Poland would not have been
sold down the river and China would have
been saved instead of betrayed I know
all that I don't know what he's going to
say he's he's a man who's well able to
make up his mind for himself
I've senator let's come back just a
moment say your point about it's perhaps
being immoral to attract Democrats into
the Republicans but my point well Dave
Engels point well my point is that you
can't possibly win by going around
shaking hands with yourself all the time
are you got to attract Democrats and
independents right are you concerned sir
about the fact that a great many new
dealers are apparently supporting
General Eisenhower would you name one
well I don't know a particular I don't
have know any but I mean well you don't
want well is it fact is it true that in
a new dealers in Massachusetts are
supporting the general I don't know I'm
asking you to name one I don't have know
a great many Democrats well I let's see
I'll attempt to name one mr. Norman
Thomas I believe that is already worried
I've lately expressed himself on this
show two three weeks ago amazing some
socialist supporting some of the other
candidates for all I know we have
millions and millions of supporters it
isn't an exclusive club we welcome
everybody I said that's the point I mean
that I'm trying to make is that you as a
Republican leader you are quite anxious
to get Emma Kratz and even new dealers
to vote for the general if necessary
are they finding a tractable problem in
arithmetic that if every Republican came
out to vote it would only be 31% of the
vote
well you just can't win with 31% you've
got to augment it but you've got to get
Democrats or independents where else can
you go
following Eisenhower is very sweeping I
think you can say and sweeping victory
in Massachusetts New York New Jersey and
other states recently do you think his
chances for
winning on the first ballot are pretty
good at this point it's impossible to
tell about the ballot this time this far
ahead you can't tell whether it's the
first to the second to the third of the
fourth it's impossible to tell
do you have let me ask you this as his
principal campaign manager or as one of
his campaign managers have you been
satisfied with the campaign to date sir
as it going along the lines that have
been any surprises for you well I'm the
fella who's been running it and I don't
suppose anybody is ever satisfied with
what he does I don't think any man feels
he's done his best work all the time
I've had some disappointments of course
what are your plans under Lodge once
general eisenhower is nominated well I'm
a candidate for re-election to the
United States Senate in Massachusetts
you would not want to be his campaign
manager for example well I don't know
whether I'd want to be I don't know I
know it's hard for you to understand
this but I look up to that convention I
don't look much beyond it well now do
you have any much to do between now and
the convention that there isn't any time
to speculate about what happens after
the convergence have you any announced
opposition in Massachusetts as yet oh
yes is a young mr. Kennedy going to be
your opponent there he's lost it
he's already announced do you expect to
have any is there any opposition in the
Republican primary not yet no and you
don't expect any I don't know of any but
I know the politics is an eternal
mystery and it's full of surprises
that's what makes it interesting now
would you care to predict for us sir as
to how many votes general eisenhower
will have by June the 20th
I've never made a prediction in my life
I say that we're ahead now I say that
the polls that have put it in the papers
are incomplete necessarily so because
they don't know the inwardness of all
these situations the way I do
so the polls and the papers are
misleading where do you how many
committed delegates do you claim for the
general I'm not claiming anything
numerically at all at any time would you
say that the tapped forces have been
stopped and it from here
and they're not going to gain
substantially well when when the Ohio
primary is held Senator Taft is going to
make some gains but that is something
that has been anticipated I'm talking
now in tangier apportion he I don't
think he's going to make any gains in
the in the true sense out he's going to
get his his hard core of votes that
we've all known that he's had but he
isn't going to gain anything outside of
a senator as they as a final question
sir and speaking as a Republican leader
do you think that there will be any
really serious wounds in the Republican
Party as a result of this coming
convention do you expect to see a United
Party after the convention whoever gets
the nomination I do at the present time
I certainly do and I certainly hope so
I think Eisenhower is going to be
nominated I think Eisenhower appeals to
all elements in the Republican Party all
factions all groups he showed it in New
Hampshire he shown in every New Jersey
Massachusetts everywhere they've had a
chance to express themselves well
senator I'm sure that our audience very
much appreciates your views tonight and
thank you very much for being with us
sir okay the editorial board for this
edition of the launching
Kronus cope was mr. William Bradford
Huie and mr. Ogden Reid jr. our
distinguished guests was the honorable
Henry Cabot Lodge jr. United States
Senator from Massachusetts
here are views of the famous Mobil gas
economy run time by launching as
official watch for the American
Automobile Association we were happy to
cooperate because it's the type of event
of which we approve an open contest fair
war where the results win or lose are
made public our congratulations to Mobil
gas and you know that it was in just
such open competitions that launching
became in fact the world's most honored
watch yes in World's Fairs competition
the results win or lose are published
and here launching watches have won
highest honors where ever entered a
total of 10 world's fair grand prizes
and 28 gold medal Awards yes and in
Observatory accuracy contests too long
gene watches have won innumerable honors
for accuracy at all the great National
observatories now if you wish to own
just about the finest watch made
anywhere in the world
your choice might well be launching the
world's most honored watch as a gift for
any important occasion or for yourself
no other name on a watch means so much
as launching the world's most honored
watch premier brought up to the long
gene wit nor watch company since
eighteen sixty six maker of watches of
the highest character
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host Frank Knight inviting you
to join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
launch in Crona scope a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most honored watch and wit
nor distinguished companion to the world
honored lawn team sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display this emblem agency for lawn jean
wit nor watches
most honored
lawn gene watches have won 10 world's
fair grand prizes twenty eight gold
medals and more honors for accuracy than
any other timepiece launching the
world's most honored watch is made in
guaranteed by the lawn gene with no
watch company it's time for the
launching promise toe a television
journal of the important issues of the
hour
trot show you every Monday Wednesday and
Friday a presentation of the lawn gene
with snore watch company maker of
launching the world's most honored wat
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene good evening
our co-editors for this edition of the
launching chroma scope our William
Bradford Huie
editor the american mercury lucien
Warren Washington correspondent of the
Buffalo courier express our
distinguished guests for this evening is
the honorable Herbert Lehman United
States Senator from New York the
opinions expressed are necessarily those
of the speakers
senator Lehman our chrono scope audience
of course knows you sir
for your long and distinguished public
service career as governor of New York
your humanitarian service with Unruh and
now is senator from New York and we
understand sir that your paramount
interest now is in immigration now why
is the question of immigration an issue
at the present time sir
well mr. Huey are big that is of great
importance today because the present
immigration laws go back to 1924 and
they're based on the 1920 census they
are confusing complicated based on
intolerable concepts of racism and
racial discrimination they need
humanizing liberalizing and codify there
is another important reason why we have
to take up the matter because the
president recently suggested to the
Congress that 3 at least 300,000
additional persons be admitted into this
country refugees from communist tyranny
and surplus peoples from Italy Greece
the Netherlands in western Germany they
are pending in Congress today two bills
on immigration one the McCarran water
bill and the other a substitute bill the
Humphrey Lehmann deal senator Lehman I
understand that you are not particularly
in favor of the McCarran water bill
could you tell us what some of our
provisions are in favor image against it
because I think the law and the current
bill rather uses police measures and
fixes racist principles and
discrimination into our laws which are
utterly repugnant to American ideals the
some of the defects of the McCarran
Walther bill are that discretion with
regard to the admission of people is
left entirely to the consuls abroad and
based on his opinion not on facts and
there's no appeal from that opinion I
believe the bill would slam the door on
future immigration I believe it would
threaten hundreds of thousands of aliens
now in this country with deportation on
technical and unsubstantial grounds and
finally by threat of
a vacation of citizenship it would for
cloud citizenship of thousands literally
thousands of people who have been
naturalized or maybe naturalized in the
future but may I give you just ago has
some examples of what I mean take the
question of deportation under the
McCarran bill an alien in this country
thirty years with white American wife
children grandchildren could be deported
they've committed if he had committed a
crime however insignificant twenty five
or thirty years ago he could be suddenly
seized and deported and sent back to
Greece Hungary Italy with no chance of
ever seeing his family again another
alien might have lived here 30 or 40
years way back in the 1920s let us say
he might have belonged to an
organization which Attorney General now
find subversive the alien might have
severed connection with this
organization twenty years ago more but
under the McCarran bill not only could
it be seized and deported no matter how
low abiding since then but no it would
have no chance of appealed the question
of the revocation of citizenship which i
think is a thoroughly evil thing the
constitution of course our constitution
of course says that there is no
distinction between native-born and
naturalized citizens yet the McCarran
bill authorizes the revocation of
naturalization taking away of
citizenship for acts not serious enough
to constitute even a crime for
native-born citizens just a couple of
instances on that a naturalized citizen
refuses testimony before congressional
committee investigating subversive act
he can be deprived as citizenship if
this refusal is within ten years
after you had been naturalized and
another naturalized citizen joins a
communist front organization for any
purpose or reason within five years of
his naturalization naturalization and
his citizenship could could be could be
taken away from them I have an answer to
all that Senator and going on
legislation you have an answer to that
in the story yes I have
I want to say that the macaron bill
would create a huge number of
second-class citizens constantly under
threat of losing American citizenship
now famous newspaper columnist recently
said if this pending legislation the
McCarran Waldo bill should be enacted we
might as well take the Statue of Liberty
out of New York Harbor and send it back
to France from whence it came now our
bill the Humphrey Lehmann bill
safeguards to the fullest extent
possible civil rights and liberties even
per aliens if not only revises and
codifies but also liberalizes and
humanizes are present immigration laws
it makes it possible for an increased
number of worthy immigrants to come to
this country we pooled the unused quotas
today the unused quotas which come
because such a large number in way back
in nineteen four in 1924 were assigned
to the northern countries like England
and Holland and Belgium and France and
not use we pull those and use them for
cut for people anywhere in the world
from which they may come and that means
the admission not the increase in the
total number of immigrants because that
will still be limited to 150,000 but
increases the number that actually can
be increased and will be increased by
about 80 or 90 thousand I believe to
that it is important as we do in our
bill to lay emphasis on the importance
of family unit and the desirability of
reunit reuniting divided families and
finally it would improve relations with
peoples in Europe not only by permitting
increased immigration into this country
but by removing racial and national
discrimination which have aroused deep
antagonism against us among peoples
abroad for Senator I'm sure that our
audience very much appreciates your
views on immigration
now tonight in the news is the steel
seizure the
and seizure of the steel properties and
has been a great deal of criticism now
are you sir generally in sympathy with
the president's action I think the
president had no alternative but to
seize the steel companies I think tooth
if he hadn't two things would have
happened if a Senate Ben had been made
on the basis demanded by the steel
companies in other words an increase of
$12 a ton which in my opinion was
entirely unjustifiable it would have
inevitably led to serious and violent
inflation which would have been a great
threat to the solvency and security of
this country and furthermore if he
hadn't seized the steel mills it would
have meant a curtailment possibly of as
much as five to seven million tons of
steel a greatly needed commodity which
is in short supply and would have then
in that way threatened our defense
activities our security and our national
economy and you I don't think the
President had any alternative and you
are not gravely concerned over the
constitutional issue that's been raised
here I'm not a constitutional lawyer and
I can't express any opinion but I
believe that a present and it's been
shown I think by the history of this
country and not only has the right but
the duty to do everything he can to
safeguard the security of his of our
country now I think the security of our
country could easily have been
threatened by a steel strike and I think
the present under those circumstances
did the only thing that any courageous
and right thinking president could have
done by seizing the steel mills senator
may I take the questioning into the
political field for a moment we are
having some conventions coming up I
understand you're going to New York
tomorrow at a dinner honoring W Averell
Harriman at which there will be some
presidential candidates number one on
the political questions do you have any
preference for a
at this time on the Democratic ticket I
am going to the dinner I'm going to
speak there I have not I have not
expressed my views up to the present
time with regard to the candidate on the
Democratic ticket or on the Republican
ticket I see but after the dinner I
believe on there's to be a meeting and a
favorite son from New York is to be
selected is that right yes on Friday I'm
consulting with some of the other
Democratic leaders in New York and we
will discuss the whole situation do you
a favor a candidate for the US Senate
two for the seat on hell by Irving M
Ives for the Democratic no I don't think
one that has been discussed at all still
I have not discussed it that field in my
opinion is wide open but we have not
have not reached and what is it what is
your opinion sir as a final question
what is your opinion of mr. Averell
Harriman I have a very high regard for
Averell Harriman I have known him for a
great many years and in my opinion there
is no more patriotic no more abled man
in this country of ours of than april
Harrell well thank you very much for
being with us sir thank you the
editorial board for this edition of the
launching promise cope was William
Bradford Huie editor the american
mercury lucian Warren Washington
correspondent of the Buffalo courier
express our distinguished guests was the
honorable Herbert Lehman United States
Senator from New York
the big news in the world of sports is
the opening of the major league baseball
season this year as four years past all
umpires of both American and national
baseball leagues will use long gene
watches exclusively for timing all games
throughout the season winding up with
the World Series in the fall it is a
fact that Longines official watch for
leading sports and contest associations
the world over including
the contest board of the American
Automobile Association the American
powerboat Association the National
aeronautical and for 1952 again the
United States Olympic Committee has
selected lawn gene watches for timing
all events for the selection of the
United States Olympic team why is this
so well the answer is found in the
greater accuracy which is inbuilt into
every lawn gene watch accuracy as an
established fact proven year after year
in the competitive accuracy trials
conducted by the great government
observatories that is why throughout the
world no other name on a watch means so
much as launching
the world's most honored watch premiere
product of the lawn Jean wit nor watch
company since eighteen sixty six maker
of watches of the highest character
you
this is David Ross speaking for your
regular host Frank Knight inviting you
to join us every monday wednesday and
friday evening at the same time for the
long gene chronicle a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honoured Longy sold and serviced from
coast to coast by more than four
thousand leading jewelers who proudly
display the emblem agency for long jean
wit nor walker
you
you